cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I'm going to pull up this
here video clip you gave to me earlier
Ian this is from Colin rugg on Twitter
and it's actually quite amazing he says
CNN is now listing out all of President
Joe Biden's lies as the New York Post
and Washington Post are also ramping up
their criticism of Biden weird how they
all changed their tune at the same time
here are the lies CNN now let's talk
about witnessing a bridge collapse
grandfather died days prior to his birth
Amtrak conductor conversations being in
New York that after 9 11 being arrested
in a civil rights protest driving 18
wheeler visiting Pittsburgh the
Pittsburgh synagogue where people were
killed let me just play the clip for you
from CNN
fine there we go I don't know if it's
similar things but he's sort of told
some stories that don't line up quite
like
this president has a pattern at this
point of either inventing or
embellishing stories oh come on it's
breaking the news from CNN they're
figuring it out times in one speech last
month alone uh he claimed he had
witnessed a bridge collapse in
Pittsburgh when he actually showed up
about six hours later he claimed that
his grandfather had died just days
before he was born himself at the same
Hospital in fact his Grandpa died more
than a year before in a different state
not not the same hospital
um and uh and he also repeated a
favorite fall story that I and others
have debunked over and over again about
a supposed conversation with an Amtrak
train conductor he was friends with who
was actually deceased at the time the
conversation would have to take place
and that's not all there are some more
serious ones in my view uh previously in
his presidency he claimed at one point
he'd been arrested during a civil rights
protests when in other versions of the
story he just said an officer had taken
him home from a protest he said he had
visited the the Pittsburgh synagogue
where warshipers were killed in a 2018
mass shooting in fact he had actually
spoken to the rabbi but never but never
went
um and he's made a whole bunch of others
too uh he said at one point Republicans
like to bring this up he said that he
used to drive a tractor-trailer it used
to drive an 18-wheeler never happened
the White House later clarified he used
to drive a school bus at one point for
as a job briefly School Bus of course
not an 18-wheeler so whatever his
intentions whether it's you know foggy
memory about stuff that's going on
decades ago
foggy memory it's an unfortunate pattern
I love I love this I love that Colin rug
said weird how they all changed their
tune at the same time
okay that's weird now old conspiracy
theorists the media is working together
to protect the Democrats and Joe Biden
new conspiracy theory they're all coming
after Joe Biden at the same time because
they're trying to get him out of office
I hate it though as a theory
I would do whatever they could to
protect him except apparently he is the
out guy now I mean it is a sign that the
establishment that Joe Biden relies on
to continue to control the Democratic
party and to stay in the White House no
longer wants him which I think we've
known for a long time that's why he
would say yes I'm gonna run again and
the DNC and his own press secretary
would be like oh they're still mulling
it over they're still thinking about it
I mean they were they have been out of
sync for a long time and I think it's
because Joe Biden is declining and I
think that they know they can't actually
get a second term
and Kamal Harris is unpopular I mean the
thing is Joe Biden has given us some of
the best lies the bold face lies from
this man there was one today where he
said he used to teach at University of
Pennsylvania do you think we have him
paying attention to your entire career
like when do you think where does that
come from because I've heard him say
that before that he taught Somewhere In
The Deep recess of his brain was he like
an assistant at John no something no
dude look 40 years ago this was normal
in politics and he would never get
called out for it only he stole that
speech from the Irish guy or whatever
that Irish politician I think it was
it's an MBA yeah and it was in the it
was in the 80s and he's like you know he
had to hit basically drop out of the
race well they caught him for that yeah
but it's he never got caught with
anything else well so I feel bad like I
look at him and I'm like oh my gosh I
feel so bad because well he has been
lying and he's never been corrected and
so in his mind everything that he said
is true I mean like he doesn't think
that he's lying and that is the power of
like you know this like literally living
in one of the most iron-clad bubbles
anybody could be in because not only I'm
sure is this family reinforcing it but
all of the biggest mechanisms of
communication are validating what he
says or at least not challenging him so
why would you ever doubt yourself yeah I
asked this the other day he did
something it's possible to remember
because he does so much stuff but I had
said uh does he is this dementor or is
he lying and it actually could be bold
right right maybe he is so used to lying
that now that he's slipping mentally his
lies are getting Bolder and less less he
doesn't have to hide them he doesn't
have to blend them in with them they're
becoming less cohesive and coherent well
consequences change your behavior and
there's been no consequences I also he's
80. he's thinking yeah and he's you know
what he's doing after he leaves the
press conference someone who works for
him is like Mr Biden you just told all
those people you were a teacher at Penn
State it was a Penn State University of
Pennsylvania University of Pennsylvania
and he goes dumb Pricks and then he gets
in the car he's like make it true we'll
see you later no I didn't and then
they're like geez he'll fire me if I
talk back to him no no it's it's it's uh
me I think there was Little Miss
Sunshine could be wrong where the
grandfather is doing heroin and he's
like I'm an old man I don't care anymore
it's like that's where Joe Biden might
be at he's like he probably gets in the
car and they're just like well here's a
bunch of bad stuff you did and he's like
so what
he's like I'm past the average life
expectancy he's like this is my problem
this is y'all yeah no exactly I'll see
you later I mean that is kind of it I
can't imagine being his staff right now
and having to be like oh well what he
meant by I drove a truck was actually
that he drove a school bus and we all
mixed up the word for truck or when he
um when he was at I can't remember what
the event was but he was speaking
publicly and there was that
um uh congressman who had just died in a
car accident and he was asking for her
and they're like oh she was just on his
mind right it's not that he didn't
realize or completely forgot that she is
not alive anymore he was just thinking
about her like they will spin anything
they can to make this work but at a
certain point there are too many loose
threads for them to weave a blanket out
of yeah if his son wasn't like uh uh
deviant I don't think I think they would
lie until he left office but because his
son is just so viciously erratic you
can't hide it yeah I'm like convinced my
favorite personal conspiracy theory is
that so uh Hunter Biden is married again
he's married to a South African film
director and they met and got married
within 10 days which I love romance too
but that seems weird and they have a
very young son and I'm totally convinced
of convenience marriage so that when
people Googled like Hunter Biden
youngest child that kid would come up
instead of his uh Navy instead of Navy
the one he had out of wedlock and he saw
all this drama with like I think they
were trying to make it so that he was
like a nice family man and we don't
understand and there are so many
grandchildren you mix them all up
meanwhile abiding family was just
completely not acknowledging what was
happening until they had to like two
months ago and released a statement
through people
uh do you know if they got a prenup he
and this new wife of his I don't I kind
of have one because I think they're
pretty standard when you have that much
money but
oh for sure
What a Sad family yeah
I'm just like imagining what it must be
like to grow up there yeah you know like
when I grew up it was pancakes in the
morning and mashed potatoes and and we
had Dominics was that supermarket and so
we'd have like you know crummy little
T-Bones but my family they could and uh
we'd go outside and play and I had to
come home when the street lights turned
on I could not imagine this family no I
mean look respect the traumas are awful
right losing a mom and a sister but
outside of that it's like Arrested
Development I mean I have also lost my
mom at a young age and I have never done
crack cocaine wait what I mean like I'm
just saying it doesn't give you an
excuse you can actually be okay uh I
think that losing a parent is you know
and I can speak to it really clearly
like it it changes your whole life and
you you live with it forever but you
know I didn't have I mean at least I
haven't made any money off of it the way
he has it would maybe be better if I had
it's interesting because you know when
you look at parental loss
um you look at things like divorce and
by a couple different studies will show
that kids suffer more post divorce than
they do the loss of a parent through
death and a lot of that is because you
know you lose a parent to death my
husband's mother was killed when he was
16 and what happens is everybody
surrounds you they remember together you
mourn with them you're not alone in your
suffering right and actually it is
easier to get over and beyond that kind
of tragic loss than it is let's say if
somebody cheats and leaves because the
child internalizes that and says it must
be my fault right when the parent dies
they don't go okay well she she you know
Hunter didn't go okay my mom wanted to
leave me right but when you lose a
parent in other ways very often the
child will internalize it as I'm the
reason why is that I don't know I don't
understand well think about it like
when for example parents divorce let's
say it's a no-fault divorce and the
parents just go their separate ways the
child is experiencing the death of their
family now they don't have their mom and
dad in their home every single day
seeing both of them saying goodnight to
both of them they don't have 100 of mom
and dad in their world which is kind of
like a kid's food mother love father
love is like social emotional Staples in
their diet so uh now they're splitting
time or very often kids lose contact
with their non-custodial parent usually
their dad often within two years and so
they're kind of being starved of what
they need but for them there was no they
couldn't figure out why especially in
these low conflict marriages which is
the majority of no-fault divorces so the
kid goes okay this wrecked my life I'm
starved of one or both of my parents and
I'm suffering uh and there I can't put
my finger on why this happened they
weren't throwing plates they weren't
yelling at each other everything seemed
fine this was out of the blue uh it must
be me and most kids of divorce at some
point go I must be the problem you know
my parents got divorced running around
when I was like 13 to 14. and and I did
not experience that in the least bit and
you know my parents did the same way we
want you to know this is not your fault
no I get it good I was like I know it's
not I was like you guys you guys are
just going you're arguing I don't know
whatever like I think me and my my
siblings were all like just particularly
pragmatic for whatever reason did you
stay in touch with both your parents
afterwards yeah my dad my dad was only a
couple blocks away that's good so he was
still coming over to the house my
parents still got along they're just
like my parents are both very pragmatic
reasonable fairly stoic yeah so despite
their arguments and uh uh which led to
divorce they were like we're going to
work together and understand there's no
point wasting time fighting about things
we're getting divorce do what you got to
do and don't like each other but you
know you still had access to both and
you didn't have to deal with high
conflict like uh being the go between
between warring mom and dad or anything
no no yeah not really that's good I
think uh my my parents were just like
there's no point like it get to a point
where and it probably rubs off on me hey
yelling isn't doing anything for us so
let's just get divorced and then we'll
facilitate whatever we need to
facilitate in a reasonable and you know
like studious manner or not studies but
like stoic manner I'm glad that they
were able to keep it together post
divorce yeah I imagine that's what I
asked because one of them bounced and
you never saw them maybe then like years
later you start to wonder if I'm the
reason like if if you lose touch with
one of them it might not happen all at
once basically it takes but that's why I
asked because like I I can't
I can't relate to that experience like
my parents didn't just ditch me right
they got a divorce but my dad was a
couple blocks away and my parents still
interact with each other and everything
and yeah but I think that's not true for
a lot of kids right the anecdotal
experience I had an experience where I
was with someone that attempted suicide
and I felt like it was my fault that was
weird to go through that like I really
felt like I was my like I was I could
have done something different and I
probably could have done something
different but it's not didn't make it
like you you are
I like you deep feeler tender man all
good men are tender men I'm not kidding
all good men are tender men the warrior
poet you gotta have a big sword and know
when not to use it yeah but I mean I
just think good men break over the right
things
like when you're watching a movie and a
dog gets killed yes
that's like the one he's a good man the
one thing that makes me not want to
watch a movie if there's like a needless
dog death but that's why John Wick did
so well because those writers knew
exactly what they were like we're gonna
make an action movie where men cry and
it's like right when the movie starts
like his dog he was give it to her by
his wife like I'll kill him that is good
that movie's amazing but if Sadness the
problem is good to feel it because it's
like gets me back to normal but if it
derails me and I'm like oh I give up
because it's like it hurts so bad I
what's the point I don't want to go
through that again that's when it's
becomes like a a bit of a roadblock no
that's because you're not meant to be
alone like you need other people to help
you through that thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time